so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your interim
host KY small this is my stuffed an
Teeter called snoot and today we're
talking about Elma mcer The Wild West
Outlaw who became a mummy and all videos
on this channel are based on scripts the
script for this one being written by
Radu Alexander follow them social media
links below if you are so inclined
speaking of which I've also been
instructed by my higher ups behind the
scenes who pay my wages to say the words
like comment subscribe because fun facts
about human psychology and YouTube in
general here me saying that means that
people are more likely to do all three
the analytics um do not lie about that
one which is weird right cuz if you like
the videos and you want to say stuff
about them or you want to see more you'd
like comment subscribe right but I have
to say it anyway but let's get to
it in the lead up to Christmas of 1976
the Caston crew of the hit television
show The $6 million man was in Long
Beach California shooting an episode at
the Pike amusement park one scene
involved a shootout in a funhouse
between the bionic hero of the show and
an evil German spy the art director
wanted to create an altogether spookier
atmosphere for the show started
rearranging some of the props including
an old spray paint a dummy with a noose
around its head for the previous four
years the dummy had been hidden away in
a dark corner Swinging From The Gallows
barely noticed by the carts full of
scared passengers that Rush past him the
art director picked up the dummy and one
of his arms snapped off not surprising
really it was old and crummy dummy made
of brittle wax except that it wasn't as
the crew member got a closer look at the
Fallen appendage he noticed a real human
bone surrounded by tissue poking out the
dummy wasn't a dummy at all but a mummy
H this might sound like an urban legend
and it has certainly been passed around
as one over the years but it's
absolutely true the police were called
in and the discovery was initially
treated as a possible prank things only
got weirder though as the courts made
its way to the Los Angeles County
coroner's office it sustained numerous
injuries and mistreatments over the
years unsurprisingly and it shriveled
down to a lean 50 but the cause of death
was likely the copper jacket bullet
still lodged in its chest dating to the
early 20th century after about a week of
unusual leads and even more bizarre
questions detectives uncovered the true
identity of the body he was Elma mcer a
turn-of the century criminal who got
killed in a shootout with the law after
robbing a train in 1911 but that still
begged the question how exactly did a
wild west Outlaw get mummified and end
up as a prop in an amusement parked fun
house where a guy pretending to be a
robot would shoot an evil Nazi German
spy well let's explain that shall
we if we've been perfectly honest here
the best bits of elma's story happened
long after he died but we're going to
start from the beginning because that's
what we do here at biographics and as
you will see he was quite a hilarious
inept criminal more wet Bandit than Wild
West Outlaw but we're getting ahead of
ourselves we don't actually have a lot
of information about mcc's early life
mainly his military records and whatever
Scamp bits and pieces historians have
been able to dig up and Cobble together
according to his army documents El mcer
was born in Bangor Main in 1880 there's
a bit of Hanky Panky that went on with
his birth records because his mother sad
mccy was young and unmarried so to
prevent her being ostracized little Elma
was adopted and raised by s's older
brother George mcer and his wife hel
George mcer became a doctor but died
from tuberculosis or consumption in 1890
afterwards sad moved in briefly with
Helen to help raise Elma and Helen's own
son Charles it was only around this time
that Elma found out that his aunt sad
was actually his mother and he took it
well at first with the two of them even
moving into an apartment together for a
time however as he entered the terrible
teens Elma grew resentful of sad for
keeping the secret from him he took to
drinking becoming and I quote unruly and
rebell IAS and in 1895 ran away from
home MCC lived with his grandfather for
a while taking a job as an apprentice
plumber it seems he was pretty good at
this thing at least being described in a
later report as and I quote skilled
Tradesman in the plumbing profession he
even moved back in with his mother for a
spell and it started to look like he was
on the path to a quiet and happy life
but fate had other plans for Elma mcer
the year 1900 was a rough one for old
Elma his mother developed a peptic ulcer
and died of peritonitis in a then just a
month later his grandfather died of
bry's disease not much was keeping young
Elmer in bangar anymore so he packed up
his bags and started wandering the
United States looking to make his
fortunes elsewhere in the next few years
mccy drifted from state to state and
city to City applying his trade as a
plumber sometimes as a minor during this
time he usually went by Frank E Curtis
possibly because he had got in trouble
with the law elsewhere in America or
possibly because he didn't want to be
mistaken for an Irish immigrant who were
commonly discriminated against at the
time mcer was skilled at his work but he
also descended pretty heavily into
alcoholism by this point so he never
really kept a job for all that long
eventually he decided he need a change
of scenery and spotted an Army
Recruitment ad in the newspaper so he
went down to the recruitment office and
in November 1907 Elma enlisted in the
Army and there's not really much to say
about elma's time in the military
probably the most interesting thing
which is somehow fitting given the rest
of his life story is that they
misspelled his name in enlistment paper
ERS as Mardi instead of mccy and it
appeared like that in all of his army
records after that other than that Elma
was assigned to Fort leworth with the
13th infantry and he learned he could
use nitroglycerin to blow the hell up a
skill which he would later put to not
very good use during his inep and
shortlived criminal career mcer kept his
head down and served quietly for 3 years
opting not to reinlist in 1910 and
receiving an honorable discharge and
here's just a bonus fun fact about mcc's
life one of his instructors was the
future general of the entire Army
Douglas mathur oh man just name Arthur
cowboy stuff who else play Red Dead just
like you get so mad at Dutch he like
money it's like Arthur we need more
money shut up like Dutch shut up so I'm
not sure about anybody else out there
but when I play Red Dead Redemption I
just turn into Tom Hardy's character
from the Revenant and was like my pelts
nothing matters but these pelts I want
these pelts these in my PS after his
discharge mcer made his way to St Joseph
Kansas where he tried and failed to find
a before spending all of his money on
booze he met up with a friend he made in
the Army called Walter Chappel and you
can only speculate on what their
intentions were but they were arrested
for carrying around burglar tools which
was a felony in Missouri at the time
Elmer was looking at a few years of
prison time the jury found him not
guilty and he was once again a free man
in January 1911 he and Chappelle parted
ways but mcer teamed up with another guy
he met on the inside while awaiting
trial he was a hardened criminal named
Walter Jarrett and this time there was
no speculation about what their
intentions were on March 24th 1911 mcer
and several other men consisting of
Walter Jarrett and his brothers robbed
the Iron Mountain train near lenar
Oklahoma Elmer was brought in for his
demolition expertise a term we're using
very Loosely here mccy knew how to use
nitroglycerin to blow stuff up sure but
Precision was not exactly his strong
suit Elmer used so much nitroglycerin
that it blew the safe door clean across
the room through the side of the train
car and ins inside the safe were around
$4,000 in silver coins which due to
mcc's ineptitude had melted into the
safe in the explosion mcer did manage to
salvage about $450 worth and as you
might expect the others weren't happy
about it they went into a fight and
Elmer went his own way which ended up
being kind of a blessing in disguise
because the others were soon arrested
for the crime and even though his first
job didn't exactly go shall we say
swimmingly mccy decided to give the
whole crime thing another go you know if
you're first year don't don't succeed
try and try again you know blow up more
train cars why the hell not in September
of that same year he and a couple of
accomplishes snuck into a bank in and I
hope I pronounce this correctly chaten
qua Kansas after hours hoping to rob it
during the night but good old Elmer
didn't learn his lesson and used once
again way too much nitroglycerin the
explosion this time blew the alter Vault
clean off its hinges completely trash
the interior of the bank but fortunately
in this case the safe remained intact
fearing that somebody might have heard
you know the massive explosion the gang
didn't set up a second charge to open
the safe and instead just made off for
about $150 in silver coins sitting in a
tray beside the safe so he made third
less money this time but no y God loves
a TR so once again not exactly the crime
of the century but he did get away with
it and mccy had Grand Ambitions for his
third Heist on October 4th 1911 Three
Outlaws robbed a train that was carrying
a Fortune of
$400,000 in cash as a payment to the
osag nation at least that's what they
thought it was carrying in fact it was
transporting sacks of males because the
robbers wait for it got the wrong train
in the end the criminals made off with
about $46 in cash a wristwatch a coat
and a few jugs of sipping whiskey after
this frankly astonishing display of
kumot akiman the gang split up and a
posy caught up with mcer while he was
taking a quick power nap in someone's
bar after drinking his share of the
profit the posy confronted Elma and a
shootout ensued mccy was killed and
there are several stories detailing what
happened next but they all end pretty
much the same way with El mccy
overdosing on bullets and now this is
the point in most biographics videos
where we you know stop because usually
when the person dies that's the end of
their story you know they usually spend
most of their time after that being dead
and just chilling in their grave but for
mccy is where his story actually starts
to get
interesting so usually when you die you
get embalmed and the person in charge of
that in mcc's case was a guy called
Joseph Al Johnson who apparently did a
pretty good job of filling his body with
arsenic laced IM baling fluid to
preserve him for a long time and then he
just sat there and waited for someone to
claim the body but then no one ever did
and the body just sat there getting more
and more crusty and Keen to recoup the
losses he'd spent in bombing the body
Jonathan began exhibiting Elmer and
charging people to come see him dubbing
him the embed Bandit and it became quite
an attraction According to some sources
which just go to show back there there
wasn't all else to do after a few years
of this in 1916 two mysterious men
finally came in to claim elma's body
supposedly they were distant relatives
from California except a few weeks later
mcer was on display yet again at the
Patterson Carnival show this became
Elmer's life you know what we mean for
the next few decades in 1922 a guy named
Lou somne
acquired Elma for a wax figure Sideshow
titled the Museum of Crime and by that
point mcer who wasn't a very large man
to begin with who completely mummified
and shriveled up to the size of a large
child during the 1930s Elma made his way
into the hands of exploitation movie
producer Dwayne esper although whether
he bought him from Sonny or received him
as a loan is a matter of who you believe
either way the outlaw mummy eventually
made its way back to the sney family
when Dan somne took over his father's
business in the late 40s he decided to
scrap the whole museum crime thing Al
together and just put them all in
storage Elma included there's no dignity
in being the closet mummy let's be
honest so besides making a quick Cameo
was a setpiece in the 1967 horror movie
she freaks McCurdy spent the next two
decades in storage until Som sold the
entire figure collection to spoony Singh
a guy who owned the Hollywood Wax Museum
and apparently Singh didn't like Elmer
because he thought he didn't look I'm
not making this up real enough so he
sold him to to the guy who had his own
exhibit on Long Beach Pike moving back
to mccy we finally Circle back to the
beginning of our story which is
ironically the end for mcer so by this
point mcer had been passed around so
much that not only had his identity been
lost but the fact that he was a real
actual person wasn't known they just
thought he was literally just a prop or
a dummy or a wax figure or something
like that and after a while Elmer was
moved to the fun house and that's where
he spent his final few years until he
was discovered by the crew of the $6
Million Man in February 1977 Elmer's
Journey came to an end he was buried in
the Summit View Cemetery next to another
notorious Outlaw named Bill dueling thus
finally the improbable story of the Wild
West mummy came to an ignominious end so
hope everybody watching own found this
video educational entertaining and
informative I certainly found the script
all three of those things if you enjoyed
it please leave a like or a comment
below with feedback suggestions for more
things for us to cover in the future
subscribe for more content like this and
as always
go out there and have the day you all
deserve